REGULARLY SCHEDULED BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS HEARING FOR
TUESDAY JUNE TWENTY SECOND. WE
ARE ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
TODAY. AND JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS FOR
WITNESSES WISHING TO DAHLIN
THAT NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO
FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL OUR
COMMITTEE. AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE THREE THREE.
ZERO ONE. BUT THEN GO ON TO. A
FEW ANY ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS AND THE ONLY THING I WANT
TO MAKE MENTION OF IS HAPPY
BIRTHDAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US TODAY. ALL OF THE SENATORS
WANT TO COME AND WISH YOU HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO. OKAY WE'LL GET A
STARTED IN FALL ORDER THEN. AND
WILL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE. WHICH IS S. B. FOUR
EIGHTY SIX FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. AND CENTER
ARE TO LEAD AGAIN WE'RE ACTING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW
THERE'S A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES
I'LL PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHATEVER YOU READY GOOD
WELL A MIXTURE BEFORE BEGAN TO
BE HALF THE SENATE HAD
DIVERSITY SEVEN AMID BLOOM I
BRING THAT MESSAGE FROM THE
SENATE. HERE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT SENATE
BILL FORTY FOUR REGARDED
LICENSE PLUMBING CONTRACTOR
REPAIR EXEMPTION UNDER CURRENT
LAW PLUMBING CONTRACTORS ARE
LICENSED BY THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSING BOARD AND ARE
CERTIFIED TO PERFORM SURE
LATERAL INSPECTION AND MAKE
REPAIRS BASED ON THEIR
INSPECTIONS. A HOME INSPECTION
IS A PHYSICAL EXAMINATION OF A
HOME INCLUDED BUT NOT LIMITED
TO SOME PLUMBING SYSTEMS
ELECTRICAL HEATING AND GENERAL
MAINTENANCE PERFORMED FOR A
FREE IN CONNECTION WITH THE
TRANSFER OF REAL ESTATE IN A
REAL ESTATE TRANSACTION. SEWER
LATERAL INSPECTIONS ARE NOT
PART OF A TRADITIONAL HOME
INSPECTIONS SEWER LATERAL
INSPECTIONS WHICH ARE INTENDED
TO IDENTIFY SEWER LEAKS ARE
REQUIRED BY MANY CITIES AND
COUNTIES AT THE TIME OF THE
HOMES SOLD. EXISTING LAW
PROHIBITS A HOME INSPECTOR A
HOME INSPECTION COMPANY OR
EMPLOYEES OF A HOME INSPECTION
COMPANY FOR PERFORMING WORK ON
ANY HOME WHICH THEY HAVE
INSPECTED IN THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS. THESE PROHIBITIONS ARE
IN LAW BECAUSE HOME INSPECTORS
ARE NOT LICENSE HOWEVER
PLUMBER'S LICENSE BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LICENSING
BOARDS ARE ALLOWED TO INSPECT
AND REPAIR SEWER LATERALS.
CURRENTLY IT IS CONSIDERED
UNFAIR BUSINESS PRACTICE FOR A
PLUMBING CONTRACTOR TO DO BOTH
THE SEWER INSPECTION AND THE
SEWER REPAIR. IF THE COMPANY
HAS ALSO- CONDUCTED A HOME
INSPECTION ON THE SAME
PROPERTY. SB FORTY FOUR
CORRECTS THIS PROBLEM ALLOWS
CONSUMERS MORE CHOICES AND
ALLOWS THEM TO SAVE TIME AND
MONEY. SB FORTY FOUR CLARIFIES
THAT A LICENSED PLUMBER AND
CONTRACTOR CAN MAKE REPAIRS TO
A SEWER LATERA PIPE. THEY HAVE
INSPECTED EVEN IF THE A OR THE
COMPANY HAS PERFORMED A HOME
INSPECTION ON THE SAME
PROPERTY. I IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
CHIU. PROVIDED AN EXEMPTION FOR
LICENSE REVOKED INSPECTORS SB
FORTY FOUR WOULD PROVIDE A
SIMILAR EXEMPTION FOR THESE
SPECIALIST LICENSED PLUMBERS.
AND WITH ME TODAY TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS TRENT
SMITH REPRESENTING OUR BILL
SPONSORED HOME GUARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS TRENT SMITH ON BEHALF
OF HOME GUARD AGAIN THE BILL'S
IS TRYING TO RESOLVE THE
CONFLICT IN TWO BODIES OF LAW
THE PLUMBING CODE AND THE HOME
INSPECTION LAW- THERE IS- NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
NOW MOVE ON TO WIN THIS IS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. UNLIMITED YEAH
WE DO HAVE PEOPLE QUEUING UP.
IN ONE MOMENT HERE. OKAY WE'RE
GRABBING A LINE ANNOUNCER ONE
MOMENT. LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS ON WHICH MARKS
THE FOR THE PLUMBING HEATING
COOLING CONTRACTORS THE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND AT
THE TIME TO SHARE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE QUEUING UP. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE NOW MOVE ON SOON
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK. IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. SB FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO.
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE TO THEIR
OWN NOW. AND AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE TO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NUMBERING
THE CONVERSATION TO HIM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. BEGIN WITH A SUMMER
GRAYSON. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATE ARE TO LIVE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR BILL I
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
HOWEVER- I THINK- JUST THE FACT
THAT WE'RE BRINGING EXCEPTIONS
UP. IS POSSIBLY A SIGN THAT
THERE ARE SOME- ISSUES- IN
CURRENT STATUTE LAW THAT NEED-
NEED A DEEPER ATTENTION. FOR
INSTANCE- WHAT IS THAT THAT DID
THAT THE DEFINITION AND THE
ROLE THE LANE IN WHICH A HOME
INSPECTOR OPERATES VERSES A
CONTRACTOR- POSSIBLY ONE WITH
THE C. THIRTY SIX OR EVEN A
GENERAL CONTRACTOR. IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE AND DOES- DOES
STATUTE. PUT THAT DEFINITION
OUT THERE IS THERE A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE ROLE OF A HOME
INSPECTOR WHO IS NOT LICENSED.
VERSUS WHO IS INSPECTING A HOME
VERSUS A CONTRACTOR WHO'S
ACTUALLY BEEN CALLED OUT TO
DIAGNOSE A PROBLEM. AND SO-
THE- YEP GO HEAD AND THEN I'LL
HAVE FOR THE COMMENTS OKAY-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OF THE
AT THE ANSWER IS EXPERTISE
PROFESSIONALISM AND A LICENSE
THAT IS THE ANSWER REMEMBER THE
HOME INSPECTOR- DOESN'T HAVE A
LICENSE THE CONTRACTOR THE
PLUMBING CONTRACTOR DOES HAVE A
LICENSE. AND THE FACT IS WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER ABOUT THE
HOMEOWNER NOW THEY ALSO HAVE
THE OPTION TO EITHER HIRE THAT
PARTICULAR- PLUMBER FROM THAT.
COMPANY OR THEY CAN GO OUTSIDE
CALL WHOMEVER THEY WISH BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THE COUNTY OR
THE CITY WHO REQUIRES IT STILL
HAS TO HAVE IT CERTIFIED BY A
LICENSED PLUMBER. THERE'S THE
ISSUES RIGHT THERE. I THINK IF
I IF I AM MAY I THINK THE WORK
THAT. IS DONE HAS TO BE DONE
BASED ON A STATE LAW HAS TO BE
DONE BY A LICENSED CONTRACTOR
FOR INSTANCE ONE OF YOUR
WITNESSES. ARE THEY A HOME
INSPECTION GROUP THAT ACTUALLY
HOLDS A LOT OF RUMORS LICENSE
SO THAT THEY CAN. INSPECT THE
HOME AND THEN TURN AROUND AND
ACTUALLY DO THE WORK AS A
LICENSE CONTRACT WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WELL THAT'S WHAT
THE LAW WOULD ALLOW THEM TO DO
SO THE UMBRELLA COMPANY THE
HOME INSPECTION COMPANY. WILL
NOW EMPLOYS LICENSE CONTRACTORS
THEY CAN USE THEM- TO GO AHEAD
AND DO THE WORK. AND AS STANDS
RIGHT NOW YOU CAN'T BECAUSE IF
THEY DID THE INSPECTION THEY
CAN'T DO THE WORK IF THEY DID
OVER THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS SO
THIS CLARIFIES IT IT IT MAKES
IT MUCH BETTER FOR THE
HOMEOWNER. HI MAKE AND RECEIVE-
THE SERVICE THEY DESERVE
SENATOR I APPRECIATE THAT BUT I
THINK THAT WAS THE INTENT OF
THE ORIGINAL. LAW THAT DROVE-
THAT DREW A LINE BETWEEN THE
HOME INSPECTION AN INSPECTOR
AND A CONTRACTOR NOW WE'RE
HIRING CONTRACTORS TO WORK FOR
THAT HOME INSPECTOR. AND SO
THAT CONTRACTORS SIMPLY GONNA
FOLLOW FALL FALL IN LINE WITH
WHAT THAT HOME INSPECTOR SAYS
RATHER THAN THERE BEING A
CHECKS AND BALANCE TYPE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE SO AGAIN I'M
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL- BUT I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO. TRYING TO- YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S LICENSING
HOME INSPECTORS OR WHETHER IT'S
MAKING UP A CLEAR DEFINITION.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE
ELECTRICAL PROBLEM YOU DON'T
CALL HOME INSPECTOR WHEN YOU
HAVE A PLUMBING PROBLEM AND YOU
DON'T CALL HOME INSPECTOR YOU
CALL ELECT FISHIN SO WHEN THAT
ELECTRICITY COMES OUT ARE THEY
INSPECTING OR THEY DIAGNOSIS.
AND DO THEY REALLY NEED THIS
EXEMPTION TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
NEVERTHELESS I DIGRESS AND I
JUST- WILL AGAIN WILL BE
SUPPORTING UP BUT LOOKING
FORWARD TO TRYING TO FIND
CLARITY WHERE AMBIGUITY IS- IN
IS RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EMIGRATION AND ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLUE WHAT
AT THIS BILL HAVING TO DO WITH
SEWER LATERALS IS A REAL
STINKER. BOB BUT THE AUTHOR
HAVING HAD THE PERSPICACITY TO.
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S MY BIRTHDAY
LEADS ME TO MOVE THE BILL. A
MOVE BY S. EVER BLOOMING THING
BY SIMILAR GRAYSON ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME SEEING
NONE SENATE ARCHULETA JEWISH TO
CLOSE- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS ISN'T GOING TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND LET'S FIRST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. LOW HERE
FOR A YEAR BERMAN LOOM. CHEN
CHIU CUNNINGHAM DALY FONG
GIPSON MASON HOLDEN IRWIN
MCCARTY INA MULLIN SALAS CHANGE
WEBER. I BILLS- KORMAN'S
MINISTER PUSHED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TWENTY SIX K. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB FOUR EIGHT
FOUR ARCHULETA DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA ALRIGHT
BERMAN. BLOOM BLOOM HI CHEN
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM. DALLI
DALLI HI FONG. FONG HI GIPSON
GRAYSON GRAYSON HI HOLDEN.
IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA. MEDINA HI
MULLIN SALAS KING WEBER. WEBER
I. THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES THE
BILL AS A BOTH WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU RICHARD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER KILLA.
THANK YOU. NOW MOVE ON THEN TO-
FILE ITEM NUMBER. THREE THIS IS
SB FIVE THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
JONES THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE CENTER JONES PLEASE
FEEL FREE PRESENT WHENEVER
READY. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MEMBERS SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY FOUR MAKE SEVERAL
UPDATES TO DENTAL HYGIENE
PRACTICE ACT INCLUDING UPDATING
THE CURRENT BOARD MEMBERS
TERMS. TO AVOID LOSING A
CRITICAL MASS OF THE BOARD'S
MEMBERSHIP AT THE SAME TIME.
THIS WOULD CAUSE A BOARD GILES
VALUABLE INSTITUTIONAL
KNOWLEDGE BUT WOULD ALSO MAKE
IT DIFFICULT OR POTENTIALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE ARE CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND ARE COMMITTED TO
FINDING AN ELEGANT SOLUTION TO
THE APPOINTMENTS ISSUE. THAT
WORKS FOR EVERYONE. OTHER
WITNESS LINE MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE- CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL
ANTHONY LONG FROM THE DENTAL%
HYGIENE BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
AND JENNIFER TEN HILL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
JONES. WILL MOVE ON TO A
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE FEEL FREE 2% OF READING
WILL BEGIN WITH- ANTHONY LONG.
THANK YOU MISTER FIRST
CHAIRMAN. I THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
ANTHONY LUNDY EXECUTIVE OFFICER
THE DENTAL HYGIENE FOR
CALIFORNIA. WHAT IS ONE OF MANY
PROFESSIONAL LICENSING BOARDS
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
WE CONTINUALLY REVIEW AND
ANALYZE THEIR LAWS AND PROPOSED
NEW LEGISLATION OR MAN EXISTING
LEGISLATION FOR IMPROVEMENTS
UPDATES AND CLARITY TO. TO
COMPLETE THE BOARD COMMISSION.
BECAUSE THAT STORY LAGUAGE IN
SENATE BILL FIVE THREE FOUR IS
THE CULMINATION OF WORK OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS. TO
ADDRESS VARIOUS BOARD ISSUES
THESE RANGE FROM ADDITIONAL
BOARD MEMBER TERM STAGGERING TO
MAINTAIN QUORUM FOR MEETINGS.
THE OVERSIGHT OF LOCAL DENTAL
HYGIENE CLINICS TO ENHANCE
ACCESS DENTAL HYGIENE CARE FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. AND
AFFECTING WAS ON PROBATION WITH
REMEDIAL EDUCATION IF
WARRANTED. THESE PROVISIONS
WILL ENHANCE THE BOARD'S
ABILITY TO CONDUCT ITS BUSINESS
AND PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF THE
DENTAL HYGIENE PROFESSION AND
EDUCATIONAL ROGRAMS IN THE
INTEREST OF CONSUMER PROTECTION.
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR JONES
AND CAL CALIFORNIA DENTAL
HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION FOR
SPONSORING AND CO SPONSORING
THIS LEGISLATION. WITH THE
BOARD AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR APPROVAL OF SB FIVE THREE
FOUR. I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MAY HAVE AN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR LEMON
NUMBER BONTA MISSED HANNAH HILL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER CAN I HELP WITH ERIN
REED AND ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION
WORKING WITH THE DENTAL HYGIENE
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PLEASED TO HAVE A GREAT ON THE
LARGELY TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
CHANGES IN SB FIVE THIRTY FOUR.
THAT IMPROVES THE BOARD'S
OPERATIONS TO BENEFIT LICENSEES
AND CLARIFY THE DH BC THAT'S
ALREADY TO OVERSEE MOBILE
CLINIC WHICH SUPPORTS THE H. B.
C. CONSUMER PROTECTION EFFORTS
WE ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. AND AT THIS TIME
OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN I
MOVE ON TO WIN THIS IS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK.
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
THIRTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF SB FIVE
THIRTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. IN AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION BY AS IMMIGRATION
SECOND BY A SIMILAR CHEN.
CENTER JUST TO WISH TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE THIRTY FOUR JONES DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA FLORA I
BERMAN. BERMAN I BLOOM. CHEN
GEN HI CHRIS YOU. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM AYE DALLY DALLY HI
FONG. FONG HI GIPSON GRAYSON
GRAYSON HI HOLDEN. IRWIN IRWIN
HI MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN SALAS KING WEBER WEBER
HI. ELEVEN NINE ZERO KNOWS LIVE
IN EYES BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH UNDER JONES WELL NOW
THEN MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. THIS IS SB FIVE
FORTY FOUR. SENATOR LAYERED.
THIS IS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR. SB
FIVE FORTY FOUR REQUIRES AT THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
ESTABLISH TESTING STANDARDS TO
BE USED BY ALL TESTING
LABORATORIES BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
ASSEMBLY PASSED A BILL THAT WAS
VERY SIMILAR TO THIS- LAST YEAR
WHAT LEGAL CANNABIS PROJECTS
ARE REVIEWED RIGOROUSLY TESTED
AND SAFE FOR CONSUMPTION THE
INDUSTRY LACKS UNIFORM TESTING
STANDARDS CURRENTLY THERE ARE
NO REQUIREMENTS. AND THIS CAME
OUT OF A STRATEGIC PLAN A LACK
OF STANDARDIZED TESTING MEANS
DIFFERENT THINGS TO DIFFERENT
LABS OF THIS BILL WOULD IN
ESSENCE- A STAB WISHES STANDARD
TEST METHOD TO BE USED BY ALL
LAPSED HERE WITH ME TODAY VIA
PHONE IS JOSIE ROBERTO
ETHERIDGE FARMS ALECIA PRIEGO
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
<c.green>ENTER LAYERED NUMBER BONTA THE</c>
PRIMER WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING ARBEL CHAIRMAN LOW AND
SENATOR LETTER TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HEARING
THIS BILL SB FIVE FORTY FOUR MY
NAME IS JEFF EURAMERICA. I AM
REPRESENTING C. L. S. WHICH
FARMS AND SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
WE ASKED ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
IN OUR INDUSTRY WHAT THEIR MAIN
ISSUES ARE. AND CONCERNS AND-
ONE OF THE TOP ISSUES. FOR
EVERYONE ACROSS THE BOARD LARGE
AND SMALL WHAT TRUSTING. YEAH
WE'VE WAITED THREE AND A HALF
YEARS FIRST ENERGIZED TESTING.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL VERY
DOCTORS AS SENATOR LARRY DID
MENTION. AB HOW THESE.
DIFFERENT LABS THESE PRODUCTS.
THEY CANNABIS BEING TESTED EACH
LAB FREEZE. WITH A DIFFERENT
THAT PASSED AT EACH LAB BUT
ALSO WITHIN EACH LAB DEPENDING
ON HOW THE SAMPLE WAS PREPARED
HANDLE. AND MAYBE IN BETWEEN
DIFFERENT EMPLOYEES AND HOW
THEY HANDLE SH THIS BILL WOULD
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE BY CREATING
UNIFORM STANDARDS IMPACT BEST
PRACTICES FOR EVERY LICENSE LAB
TO FOLLOW THEM. ACROSS THE
BOARD AND WE CREATE ONE
UNIFIED- PROCEDURE SO THAT WE
AS LICENSE HOLDERS. CAN'T RELY
ON. WHAT PRODUCT FOR OFF IS THE
PRODUCT WE'RE DELIVERING TO.
THE PUBLIC AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US THAT WE PROVIDE
CONSISTENCY AND QUALITY
PRODUCTS WE ALL PRIDE OURSELVES
IN NOT SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HEARING THIS BILL TODAY AND WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SECOND PRIMARY WITNESSES
SUPPORT MISS BREAK UP. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS AT LEAST
APPRECIATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING MANUFACTURERS IN
THE STATE WERE IN STOCK THE
COURT OF S. B. FIVE FOUR FOUR
AND AS THE OCCURENCE SPONSOR
MENTIONED IT BALANCHINE
DETECTING. BANNER THAN
UNIFORMITY IS CRITICAL FOR
MANUFACTURERS AND PRODUCT
SAFETY HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES NOW FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THE MESSAGE CARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FORTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB. FIVE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. LIE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF
OF THE CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. AND AT
THE TIME OF DAY CARE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE FORTY FOUR. THAT'S ONE
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER IN
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. FORGET
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB. FIVE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW. IN AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NUMBER THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE SENATOR LATER DID
WAS TO CLOSE. I APPRECIATE THE-
STATEMENTS OF THE WITNESSES AND
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
FIVE FOUR FOUR WHERE DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA I BERMAN.
BERMAN HI BLOOM CHEN CHEN HI Q.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI DALLY
DALLY HI FONG FONG HI GIPSON
GRAYSON GRAYSON I HOLDEN IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MULLIN SALAS KING WEBER WEBER
HI PERFECT. ELEVEN NINE ZERO
NOW SOME OF AND I BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTERED ALERT COLLEGE AS WE
WAIT FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS TO
PRESENT THEIR BILLS IS MOVE
ONTO. CONSENT. I CAN GIVE YOU
CAN A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOTION BY VICE CHAIR
FOR SECOND BY MISTER GIBSON
TWENTY SIX VERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON CONSENT. CONSENT SB
FOUR ONE FOUR JONES DO PASSED
TO LOCAL GAP LOW HIGH LOW HIGH
FLORA. FLORA HI BERMAN. BERMAN
I BLOOM BLOOM HI CHAN CHAN HI
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
DALLI DALLI HI FONG FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON
HI HOLDEN. IRWIN IRWIN HI
MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA HI MULLIN
MULLIN I SALAS. KING WEBER
WEBER HI. FORTY NINE ZERO KNOWS.
FOURTEEN IS YOUR KNOWS WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR. ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS AS WELL. BECAUSE WE'RE
JUST WAITING FOR TO ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS.
THE OKAY. I AND. THE
BRIDGE. OKAY. THE MOBILE YEAH.
YEAH WE'LL- HAVE. SO. PERFECT
PERFECT. TOP OF THE. SO OKAY.
THE NEW. I THINK. NUMBER OKAY
OKAY REQUIRED BY LOCAL. WE. AT
THE. FIFTY OKAY. IN.
TWO NOT
ANYMORE. IF WE GET COMING CALL
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TO PLEASE
COME TO PRESENT WILL NOT WILL
ADJOURN IN FIVE MINUTES. SURE
WE HAVE THE.
I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S WORKING RIGHT NOW THE
CENTER STATEN YEAH. THANK YOU
JOHN. WHEN I MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THIS IS SB
THREE TEN BY SENATOR RUBIO
PLEASE FEEL FREE PERCENT
WHATEVER ANY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT SB THREE TEN. A
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WILL HELP SAVE SO MANY
LIVES. OF CANCER PATIENTS
ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE. THIS
BILL CREATES A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM THAT WILL ALLOW CANCER
PATIENTS TO DONATE THEIR BYING
USE MEDICATIONS TO PATIENTS.
WITH GREAT NEED THROUGH THEIR
CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN. TRAGICALLY
A RECENT STUDY SHOWS ABOUT
THIRTY FOUR MILLION PEOPLE HAVE
REPORTED KNOWING OF AT LEAST
ONE FRIEND. OR FAMILY MEMBER IN
THE PAST FIVE YEARS WHO DIED
AFTER NOT RECEIVING THE MUCH
NEEDED MEDICATION AND TREATMENT
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T AFFORD
IT. WE KNOW PATIENTS HAVE DIED
THAT'S CLEAR. AND IT'S REALLY
SAD TO ME THAT THESE PATIENTS
HAVE PERISHED BECAUSE- NOT
HAVING ENOUGH FUNDING TO PAY
FOR MEDICATION AT LEAST
FOURTEEN OTHER STATES HAVE
ALREADY SIMILAR PROGRAMS
OPERATING AND WORKING AND WE
NEED CALIFORNIA. TO CATCH UP
MEMBERS THIS MEASURE IS A
CRITICAL MEASURE THAT MAKES
SENSE AND IT HELPS THE MOST.
NEEDY OF PATIENCE I WILL END
WITH THIS BILL. HAS UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BECAUSE THIS
IS HOW IMPORTANT THIS BILL THIS
TODAY WITH ME I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE TO WITNESS THIS. FIRST
TO TESTIFY HERE WITH ME IN
PERSON IS AT. SHF WHO IS HERE
TO TELL HIS PERSONAL STORY AND
ON THE PHONE I ALSO HAVE DR
STEVE LEVY WHO WILL ALSO BE
TESTIFYING REMOTELY IF I MAKE
AND BITE HIM UP TO SPEAK.
PLEASE BUT AT. IS IT IS JUST A
EDGE MISTER KIT THIS IS AT YES
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
PLEASE HAVE WELCOMED THAT WITH
YOUR PUP PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF
YOU COULD KINDLY LIMIT YOUR
TEST NINETEEN NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER READY. HEY
GOOD MORNING. ON MAY THIRTEENTH
OF THIS YEAR MY WIFE MAGGIE
PASSED AWAY DUE TO
COMPLICATIONS FROM BREAST
CANCER. FINANCIALLY DIAGNOSED
AND TREATED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
SHE'S BEEN CANCER FREE FOR FIVE
YEARS. WHEN THE DISEASE
RETURNED IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. FLOWED BEGAN BUILDING
UP IN HER ABDOMINAL CAVITY A
CONDITION KNOWN AS A SOCIETY'S.
AND MALIGNANT BREAST CANCER
CELLS WERE FOUND THAT FLUID
THEREBY DEFINING HER CONDITION
AS MALIGNANT ASCITES HE'S-
ORDING TO THE WORLD JOURNAL OF
GASTROINTESTINAL SURGERY THE
AVERAGE SURVIVAL TIME. FOR
PATIENTS WITH MALIGNANT ASIDE
EASE SOME TWENTY WEEKS. HER
ONCOLOGIST PUT MAGGIE ON A
PROGRAM OF HORMONE SUPPRESSANTS
AN ATYPICAL CHEMOTHERAPY DRUG
CALLED CHEMOTHERAPY DRUG CALLED
PUBLIC CICHLID MARKETED BY
PFIZER. A NAME I BROWN'S. IS AN
ORAL TEAM MEDICATION TAKEN AT
HOME THUS AVOIDING REGULAR
VISITS. TO AN INFUSION CENTER
AS WELL AS THE TYPICALLY
DEBILITATING SIDE EFFECTS OF
CHEMOTHERAPY. INSTEAD OF TWENTY
WEEKS MAGGIE LIVED ANOTHER TWO
AND A HALF YEARS. SUCH
EFFECTIVENESS COMES AT A PRICE.
WITHOUT INSURANCE A MONTHLY
DOSE OF I BROWN'S TWENTY ONE
TABLETS. WHAT'S A COUPON
DISCOUNT AT THIRTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF ONE IS UNINSURED THE
NOMINAL LIST PRICES CLOSER TO
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IF THE
PATIENT IS INSURED AND VIBRANCE
IS IN IN IN THAT INTEREST FROM
FORMULAR THE MONTHLY COPAY IS
OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IMAGINE IF YOU WILL. OF SKILLED
TRADES PERSON HARD WORKING
SKILLED TRADES PERSON. IF THAT
PERSON DOES NOT QUALIFY FOR A
PROGRAM- THE FIZER RUNS
QUALIFIES RUN QUALITY TOGETHER
WITH N'GOLO KANTE THRESHOLD OF.
LESS THAN EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO TYPICALLY IS SKILLED
TRADES PERSON MIGHT BE MAKING
MORE THAN THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE FACED WITH A PAYMENT FOR A
LIFESAVING. MEDICINE IT'S A
QUOTE FROM THEIR MONTHLY
MORTGAGE THAT OF COURSE IS A
FINANCIAL DISASTER. IT HAPPENED
THAT MAGGIE'S LAST MONTH WITH
PRESCRIPTION OF IRAN'S ARRIVAL
SHE WAS ALREADY IN THE
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT. THE BOX IS
UNOPENED SEALED BY A PATCH OF
TAPE. AND WITH THE MEDICATION
INSIDE SEALED IN A BLISTER PACK
IT IS PRISTINE. IT IS AT
PRESENT ALSO TOTALLY USELESS.
SHORTLY AFTER MAGGIE DIED. I
BEGAN SEARCHING FOR A WAY TO
DONATE THE ON UNUSED UNOPENED
MEDICINE. DURING THE SEARCH I
DID NOT ENCOUNTER A SINGLE
PERSON. WE DO NOT WANT TO HELP.
BUT EVERY PERSON I CONTACTED
HAD TO EXPLAIN WHY THEY COULD
NOT HELP. THE ONLY VICE
ANYWHERE ALLOWED TO PROVIDE
CONSISTENT OF DISPOSAL
LOCATIONS. FOR MY PART I FIND
IT ASTOUNDING INTOLERABLE THAT
SOMETHING SO VERY VALUABLE
SHOULD SIMPLY BE DESTROYED. THE
FACT IT HAS BEEN IN THE
PERSONAL POSSESSION OF ANYONE
OTHER THAN A PRESCRIBING
FACILITY EXCLUDES IT FROM ANY
SORT OF DONATION UNDER CURRENT
LAW. MAGGIE'S MAY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE I BROWN'S BOX HAS A MAY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO EXPIRATION
DATE ON IT. I URGE THAT THIS
MEGA MET THIS LEGISLATION BE
ADVANCED WITH ALL THE SPEED THE
DILIGENCE ALLOWS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMPELLING TESTIMONY. WHEN I
MOVE ON TO DOCTOR LEE. HI GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS DEEPLY
I'M A MEDICAL ONCOLOGIST IN
OAKLAND AND I'M SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TEN. LIKE
TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND NOT AT
THE REPRESENTATIVE ABOUT. MY
EMPLOYER. ALLOWS ONCOLOGISTS
WITHIN STRICT GUIDELINES TO
TAKE BACK OUR PATIENTS ON USED-CANCER MEDICINES AND PROVIDE
THEM TO PATIENTS IN NEED. A
SAFE CANCER MEDICINE DONATION
PROGRAM DRIVEN BY CALIFORNIA
PATIENTS AND ONCOLOGISTS CAN
ENHANCE ACCESS TO CARE. REDUCE
HEALTHCARE WASTE AND PROVIDE
TIMELY TREATMENT TO UNDERSERVED
PEOPLE. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN I
WORKED IN A PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SOME OF MY PATIENTS HAD A
SPECIFIC TYPE OF STAGE FOR LUNG
CANCER THAT CAN EFFICIENTLY BE
TREATED WITH THE PILL. AS
OPPOSED TO TALK THE
CHEMOTHERAPY. HOWEVER DUE TO
DELAYS RELATED TO PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION OR PATIENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS THEY HAD
UNNECESSARILY UNDER UNDERGO.
ROUND OF TOXIC CHEMO TO HOLD
BACK THE CANCER WHILE THE PILLS
ARE BEING PROCESSED. ON THE
OTHER SIDE THERE OFTEN LEFTOVER
PILLS AT THE END OF THERAPY
EITHER DUE TO INTOLERANCE OR
INEFFECTIVENESS. THESE PILLS
ARE THROWN AWAY BECAUSE THERE'S
NO SYSTEM TO REPURPOSE THEM FOR
MY PATIENTS WITH NEWLY
DIAGNOSED CANCERS. THIS BILL
HAD SPECIFIC PATIENT
PROTECTIONS BECAUSE PATIENT
SAFETY IS THE FIRST OBLIGATION.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO THE
SAFEGUARDS ENSURE WE PROTECT
PATIENTS WELL WE STRIVE TO GET
THEM TIMELY ACCESS TO THE BEST
TREATMENT. FINALLY A TWENTY
SIXTEEN MEMORIAL SLOAN
KETTERING STUDY FOUND THAT
NEARLY THREE BILLION DOLLARS OF
CANCER DRUGS. WAS BEING THROWN
AWAY EACH YEAR. EAST EACH
WASTED MEDICATION REPRESENT AN
EXPENSE FOR CALIFORNIA PATIENT
AND A LOST OPPORTUNITY OR FOR
APPROPRIATE AND TIMELY
TREATMENT. OTHER STATES HAVE
HAD SIMILAR PROGRAMS SINCE
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
AND IF THAT HELPS PATIENT AND
HAVE FAITH. THEIR STATE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. WE'RE
EXCITED TO WORK TO BRING THIS
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM TO
CALIFORNIA ON. BEHALF OF OUR
PATIENTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MEDICARE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE TEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB THREE
TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE TO THEIR
OWN NOW. IN ONE MOMENT TO SHARE
WITH YOU HAVE SOMEONE COMING UP.
LIE NUMBER THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LOVE
HEARING MEMBERS OF AUTOMOBILES
MOST OF THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY TRANSACTION NETWORK
PROMPTING SPONSORED SB THREE
CHANGE I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AT THIS CRITICAL PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THANK YOU. AND
AT THIS TIME IF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE UP TO THE LINE
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN. OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SB THREE TEN. PUSH
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER. IN PLACE YOU
BACK INTO THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB THREE TEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW. AND AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WHEN THEM IN
THAT CONVERSATION BACK TEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. DR WEBER. THANK YOU
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
FOR THIS- MUCH MUCH NEEDED BELL
AND I WE WILL DEFINITELY BE
SUPPORTING IT. I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- MORE ABOUT THE
VISION AND KIND OF LIKE. HOW
THIS WILL UNFOLD- I KNOW THAT-
YOU HAD SB SIX FIFTY- WHICH-
UNFORTUNATELY WITH HOLDEN
APPROPRIATIONS- BECAUSE I THINK
THAT CREATING. THE CANCER
MEDICATION ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WHICH THAT BILL WAS DOING.
WOULD HAVE- INVESTIGATED AND
ANSWERED MANY OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT I HAVE AS FAR AS THE
PROCESS OF ACTUALLY CREATING
SOMETHING LIKE THIS. SO ONE OF
MY QUESTIONS DEALS WITH THE
FIFTY- PARTICIPANT CAP WHICH
MAY OR MAY NOT STAY NOW THAT
THE- CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD
IS OUT. BUT MY QUESTION IS WHAT
EXACTLY IS- THE PARTICIPATING
PRACTITIONR IS THAT. ONE
INDIVIDUAL THAT APPLIES AND IS
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. OR IS THAT
ONE INDIVIDUAL THAT APPLIES. ON
BEHALF OF THEIR FACILITY.
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES N. THESE
KIND OF SITUATIONS- YOU'LL HAVE
ONE PARTICULAR PROVIDER IN A
CLINIC OR A HOSPITAL THAT WILL
GO TO THE TRAINING APPLY FOR
WHATEVER AND THAT PERSON IS ON
RECORD FOR THAT ENTIRE CLINIC
OR FACILITY SO THAT IT'S NOT
JUST LIMITED TO THAT ONE.
PROVIDER THAT CAN PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM. SO ARE WE
SAYING ONE OF PROVIDER OF ONE
PERSON OR ONE PROVIDER IS GOOD
FOR THAT SPECIFIC CLINIC OR
THAT SPECIFIC HOSPITAL. HELLO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
YES OFFERED THROUGHOUT THE
FIFTY CAP CAME FROM US TRYING
TO MINIMIZE THE COST. ON WHEN
THE NETWORK WAS GOING TO BE
RUNNING THIS PROGRAM BUT WE
FOUND ANOTHER. MORE INEXPENSIVE
WAY OF DOING THIS CELLS SO WE
MAKE CONSIDERING MOVING THE CAP
AND I TO HAPPINESS THAT HERE
WITH US FOR AT TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF. IF SHE
MAKE THANK YOU. CHIEF JUSTICE
FOR. SHORT WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
ONCOLOGIST THANKS SO MUCH FOR
THE QUESTION DOCTOR WEBER- WE
ARE INTENT IS TO HAVE IT BE
EVERY OTHER PHYSICIAN
PARTICIPATE WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO BE
REGISTERED- AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY SIGNED ALL THE PAPERWORK
AND THE KIND OF APPRECIATE THE
RULES THAT GOES ALONG WITH IT
FOR HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR
OFFICE IF YOU HAVE. OTHER IDEAS
GIVEN YOUR UNIQUE ROLE HERE AND
WE'RE WELCOME HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOUR OFFICE AND SEE IF YOU
HAVE ADDITIONAL A LANGUAGE THAT
YOU THINK WE NEED TO INCLUDE
BUT ARE INTENDED FOR IT TO BE
EVERY PHYSICIAN- MUST BE
REGISTERED. OKAY YEAH I WOULD I
WOULD LOVE TO DISCUSS THAT
FURTHER BECAUSE THAT CAN
SOMETIMES BE A LITTLE BIRD AND
SOME- AND PHYSICIANS KIND OF
COME AND GO AND SO YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL PATIENTS AND
ALL FACILITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS- PARTICULAR PROGRAM SO THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAD- HAS TO DO
WITH THE SELECTION CRITERIA I
WASREADING- IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND YOU KNOW I A I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE KNOW BUT BOTH
MY BROTHER AND FATHER HAD
CANCER AT THE SAME TIME MY
BROTHER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH NON
HODGKINS LYMPHOMA AND THEN A
MONTH LATER MY DAD MY DAD WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH- MULTIPLE
MYELOMA AND IT WAS NECESSARY
VERY CRITICAL TO START
TREATMENT VERY QUICKLY- FOR
BOTH OF THEM AND I KNOW THAT'S
ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT WAS
STATED- IN HERE FOR IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PARTICULAR BELL. BUT I
DON'T SEE ANYTHING ABOUT HOW
PEOPLE GET SELECTED- ARE WE
FOCUSING ON ANYBODY IS THERE A
SPECIFIC CRITERIA THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE EITHER UNDERINSURED OR
WITHOUT ANY INSURANCE HAVE
SPECIALIZED PREFERENCE OR IS IT
JUST BASED OFF OF WHO HAS THE
DIAGNOSIS EVEN IF YOU HAVE
INSURANCE BUT YOU MAY HAVE A
DELAY IN YOUR INSURANCE-
ACTUALLY AUTHORIZING THE
MEDICATION IS THERE ANY KIND OF
SELECTION CRITERIA FOR THIS
PROGRAM. WHAT WE WANTED TO
FOCUS ON THAT AND THE HIGHEST
NEED THAT URGENT NEED BUT I'M
GONNA LET THE SAID ANSWER OUT
FURTHER. THE SET. WE LOOKED AT
OTHER STATES PROGRAMS TO ASSESS
IF BASS SELECT. KIND OF AT A
STATE LEVEL THE SELECTION
CRITERION ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
MANY OTHER STATES LEAVE IT TO
THE SPECIFIC OFFICE- BASED ON
THEIR PATIENT POPULATION AND
THE NEED THAT THEY SEE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. I'M I BELIEVE THE
AUTHORS TAKING LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD MAKE IT CLEAR IN THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THAT
EACH- A PROVIDER IN EACH OFFICE
HAS TO CREATE. AROUND THIS
PROGRAM THAT THEY MUST CREATE
THEIR OWN ELIGIBILITY- AND
DISTRIBUTION CRITERIA TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT IS KIND OF WELL
THOUGHT OUT AND- DOCUMENTED-
PRIOR TO THE INITIATION OF THE
PROGRAM. SO THAT WOULD SO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT THE
SELECTION CRITERIA WOULD BE
DEPENDENT ON THAT PARTICULAR
CLINIC OR HOSPITAL. YES OKAY SO.
ONE PARTICULAR CLINIC MAY
CHOOSE TO- HAVE A SELECTION
CRITERIA THAT WOULD REALLY
SERVE THE UNDERSERVED AND SELF
I AM IN THAT AREA THEN YOU KNOW
AND I DON'T HAVE INSURANCE THAT
I WOULD HAVE A GREATER BENEFIT
FOR THAT HOSPITAL BUT ANOTHER
PERSON IN ANOTHER AREA IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT SELECTION
CRITERIA THAN THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE UNDERSERVED WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY GET THAT SAME.
BENEFIT BECAUSE THERE'S
DIFFERENT CRITERIA BASED ON THE
HOSPITAL. WELL WHAT I WILL SAY
THIS- AGAIN GIVING YOUR
BACKGROUND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WERE OPENED TODAY TO DISCUSS-
INITIALLY WE REALLY FOCUS ON
THE SAFETY OF THE PATIENT FIRST
WE WANTED A PATIENT. PHYSICIAN
RELATIONSHIP OR THE PHYSICIAN
GETS TO DECIDE BUT LIKE I SAID
THAT URGENCY FACTOR AND- AND
WE'RE STILL EXPLAIN FURTHER IF
YOU KNOW WE ARE GOING TO MEET
THE BILL TO TRY AND REMOVE THE
CAP OF FIFTY TO INCLUDE TO
REMOVE THE MET PORTS SO IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT. YOU WANT TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH ME ABOUT
WE CAN DEFINITELY TO YOUR
THOUGHTS IN THIS WE WANT THIS
TO BE EFFECTIVE WE WANT THIS TO
SAVE LIVES AND WE WANTED TO DO
IT IN THE BEST POSSIBLE MANNER-
AGAIN I KNOW THERE'S A REAL
HUMAN FACTOR TO THIS SAYS YOU
KNOW MIGHT WITNESS STATED. YOU
KNOW WE HAVE FAMILIES THAT ARE
DYING BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE FINANCIAL MEANS AND THEN WE
HAVE OTHER FAMILIES HOLDING ON
TO THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS WORTH
OF MEDICATION SO ANYTHING THAT
YOU CAN SAID JASSIM RAINFOREST
WERE STILL MANY IN THE BILL WE
ARE GLAD TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AND INCLUDE WHAT YOU
THINK IS APPROPRIATE. TO MEET
YOUR CONCERNS. WHAT YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS AND I WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH YOU MY OFFICE WILL
CONTINUE TO CONTACT YOUR OFFICE
ON BECAUSE I DEFINITELY THINK.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND WHEN WE
ROLL IT OUT WE WANT TO ROLL IT
OUT THE BEST WE WANT TO ROLL
OUT THE BEST POSSIBLE PROGRAM
WE CAN'T SO THAT. OTHER STATES
WILL MODEL AFTER OUR-
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- I HAD. A AND
FOUR TO OVERLOOKED OF. WITNESS
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK AND- SENATE SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME IS THAT IS THAT RIGHT.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME INTO
THE MATCH NO WE ALREADY HAD
THAT. NOBODY'LL EMILY HUGHES
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENA ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS AT
THIS TIME WE'LL GO BACK TO ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'VE DONE A-
IT ADDITIONAL IS ALREADY BEEN.
THE BENEFITS OF THERE'S ALREADY
BEEN A MOTION AND SECOND
SENATOR RUBIO JEWISH TO CLOSE
JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS FELL
AGAIN- THIS IS JUST ONE STORY
WITH MY WITNESS HE'S TELLING
HIS STORY BUT THERE'S HUNDREDS
OF INDIVIDUALS HAVE REACHED OUT
TO OUR OFFICE THROUGHOUT- LAST
YEAR SINCE WE INTRODUCED THE
BILL LAST YEAR AND WE REALLY
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THIS MEDICATION
SITTING THERE WHILE THE COULD
SAVE. A LOVED ONE'S LIFE SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR SENATE RUBIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR EMPATHY AND
ALSO PASSION ON THIS ISSUE AS
YOU CAN TELL FROM WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IS IT HAS AN
IMPACT ON MANY INDIVIDUALS
LIVES THIS DOES STILL- GO TO
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AS WELL
AND CERTAINLY ENCOURAGED THAT
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WITH
OTHER COLLEAGUES TO HELP
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INPUT AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE. WITH THAT
SAID COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SB THREE TEN
RUBIO DO PASSED HEALTH
COMMITTEE LOW HIGH LOW HIGH
FLORA FLORA I BERMAN. BERMAN HI
BLOOM. BLOOM HI. CHAN HI Q.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DELI
DELI HI FONG. FONG HI GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON HI
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. IRWIN
HI MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS
SALAS EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN HI
WEBER WEBER HI. EIGHTY NINE
ZERO KNOWS IT'S NICE BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND RUBIO. BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO END UP WITH A
FIREARM. SB TWO FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR UMBERG. WELCOME THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I
PLEASE PRESENT SB TWO FORTY ONE
WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA COURT
EFFICIENCY ACT IT HAS TO
PROVISIONS OF THE FIRST IS.
TAKING LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
PANDEMIC WITH RESPECT TO COURT
EFFICIENCY IT SIMPLY PROVIDES
THAT IF TWO PARTIES STIPULATE
THAT A WITNESS MAY APPEAR
REMOTELY THAT WITNESS MAY THEN
APPEAR VIRTUALLY IF THE COURT
HAS THE TECHNOLOGY TO BE ABLE
TO PERMIT THAT- IF THEY ON'T
STIPULATE AND ONE PARTY MOVES.
IN THE COURT FOUR BECAUSE A
LAWS OF TO SPEND TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY- THEY CAN DO SO- THERE
ARE MANY CRITERIA THOUGH THAT
GO INTO THE EVALUATION AS TO
WHETHER WITNESS CAN APPEAR
REMOTELY- THIS SAVES.
TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF MONEY
BOTH FOR LITIGANTS AS WELL AS
THE PARTIES SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS WHO WOULD
BE REALLY A MINISTERIAL WITNESS
MAY NOT ACTUALLY SHOW UP AND
WAIT TO TESTIFY. THEY COULD DO
SO FROM THEIR OFFICE IN THE
SAME THING GOES WITH RESPECT TO
PRO SE LITIGANTS A RATHER THAN
COMING TO COURT PARTICULARLY
FOR. A PRO FORMA HEARINGS THEY
CAN DO SO EITHER ELECTRONICALLY
FROM THEIR HOME OR THEY CAN GO
TO FOR EXAMPLE LEGAL AID AND
CONNECT THROUGH LEGAL AID
THAT'S PART ONE OF THE BILL
PART TWO OF THE BILL- SIMPLY
ALLOWS- CLEARS UP BASICALLY.
WHAT OUT OF STATE COURT
REPORTERS CAN DO. IN TERMS OF
TRANSCRIBING DEPOSITIONS IT'LL
BE USED IN CALIFORNIA PROVIDES
THAT THEY'LL BE A LOCAL COURT
REPORTING FIRM THEY'LL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE OUT OF
STATE COURT REPORTING FIRM IT'S
ANALOGOUS TO LOCAL ATTORNEYS
BEING ASSOCIATED IN A CASE
WHERE YOU'RE OUT OF STATE
ATTORNEYS WHO ARE HANDLING
PRIMARY PRINCIPAL SPONSOR
ABILITIES. ARJAN I VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER AMBER WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I SEE THAT
THERE ARE TWO IF YOU COULD
KINDLY LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES EACH.
WILL BEGIN WITH THE FIRST
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. AND HE SAID
THAT THAT WE HAVE THE CHAIR
FROM THE COURT REPORTERS BOARD.
MORNING I'M ROBIN SON SHE'S
CHAIR OF THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD THANK YOU SHARE LOW ONE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
ABOUT AN- UNCOMPLICATED. WELL
THAT IT FISCALLY SMART SOLUTION
IN SB TWO FORTY ONE. THAT WOULD
ENSURE THAT ALL CONSUMERS OF
COURT REPORTING SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE PROTECTED
WHETHER THEY SECURE THOSE
SERVICES THROUGH A FIRM OWNED
BY LICENSEE. OR CORPORATION
KNOCKED DOWN BY A LICENSEE. IT
ISN'T THAT SIMPLE THIS IS ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTION. THE COURT
REPORTER'S TRANSCRIPT IS AN
IMPORTANT DOCUMENT BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER THE TRIAL.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURES
LEGISLATORS HAVE PAINSTAKINGLY
CRAFTED LAWS TO INCLUDE
DETAILS. AND SPECIFICITY ON
EXACTLY HOW THE RECORD SHOULD
BE HANDLED TO UPHOLD THE
INTEGRITY OF COURT REPORTING IN
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM. WE ARE
HERE BEFORE YOU BECAUSE THE
BOARD'S ABILITY TO SERVE AND
PROTECT THE CONSUMERS HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED. BY NOT
BEING ABLE TO ENFORCE THESE
LAWS WITH FIRMS OWNED BY A NON
LICENSING. COMPLAINTS RECEIVED
BY THE BOARD INCLUDING BILLING
IRREGULARITIES AND TRANSCRIPT
MISCONDUCT IN ALLOWING ONE SIDE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO A TRANSCRIPT
BEFORE THE OTHER. HEREBY GIVING
THEM AN ADVANTAGE OF PREPARING
FOR LITIGATION. THE BORDERS
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THE ACTUAL
ENFORCEMENT ARM AT THE BOARD
FOR THE SIMPLEST SOLUTION TO
pREPORTING SERVICES. TO THE
STANDARDS ESTABLISHED BY THE
LEGISLATURE NO MATTER WHERE
THEIR HOME TATE IS LOCATED. SB
TWO FORTY ONE A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS TO KNOW
THEY HAVE SOMEONE TO TURN TO.
NAMELY THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD SHOULD THEY EXPERIENCE AN
ETHICAL ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR BY A
COURT REPORTER. OR A COURT
REPORTING FIRM. THE BOARD
WELCOMES DIVERSE BUSINESSES
BECAUSE COMPETITION IS GOOD FOR
THE CONSUMER. ITS FIRST HEALTHY
BUSINESS RAISES THE QUALITY OF
PERFORMANCE LOWERS PRICES AND
EXPAND. ACCESS TO GOODS AND
SERVICES WHAT IS NOT GOOD FOR
THE CAN IS TO HAVE THE UNABLE
TO SEE IN FOR THE LAW. THAT
WERE GIVEN IT TO YOU GIVEN TO
IT BY THE LEGISLATURE. WE THANK
SENATOR- BURKE AND HIS STAFF
FOR THEIR DEDICATION TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION. AND THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US. ON AMENDMENTS TO THE
REPORTING PORTION OF THE BILL.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY ONE FOR
EQUAL PROTECTION OF ALL
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE THE SECOND WITNESS IN
SUPPORT FROM THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO
BE AN ATTACK OUT THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA AT
COUPON DIRECTLY TO FORTY ONE.
THE BILL ADOPTED CORPORATION
FEEDBACK AUTHORISING CERTAIN
NON PRIMARY WITNESSES TO APPEAR
IN COURT BY LIVE REMOTE VIDEO.
A CALIFORNIA COURT GRADUALLY WE
OPEN TO NORMAL OPERATION IT'S
CLEAR THAT ENORMOUS BACKLOG OF
CRIMINAL AND CIVIL CASES WILL
REQUIRE FOCUSED AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO WRITING JEFF TO DO
IT AGAIN. ESTIMATES ARE THAT
THE TOTAL BACKLOG WILL REQUIRE.
SEVERAL YEARS AT LEAST TO
RESOLVE. ALTHOUGH IT IS THE
THIRD PRIME ARE CRITICAL.
APPEAR IN COURT TO TESTIFY.
EVEN IF THE LINE HAUL OF THE
COURT TO WAITING A DAY OR
TAKING AN ENTIRE DAY OFF OF
WORK. ALTHOUGH THEY'RE NOT
PRIMARY WITNESS IN THE CASE.
DUE TO SAFETY CONCERNS AND
CONVENIENCE THE WITNESSES AT
THE G. FORTY ONE WOULD ALLOW
EVEN IF IT HEREBY LIVE REMOTE
VIDEO.EVERYONE ELSE FOR ME IN
THE COURTROOM. TESTIMONY HAS
BEEN TAKEN INTO COURT FOR
DECADES DO TELEPHONIC BY COURT
CALL. AND WE'VE BEEN IN A
PANDEMIC AND DO PILOT OF REMOTE
HEARING LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
ONCE THE DATE OF EMERGENCY AND
SHE JUST THE FLEXIBILITY TO
MOVE CASES FORWARD TO REMOTE
MEANS WELL AND WELL IF WE DON'T
ACT. SB TWO FORTY ONE OF THE
VERY MODEST AND MINOR APPROACH
TO OPERATE ONLY BE THE
WITNESSES. ARE MOSTLY IN
APPROVED BY A JUDGE JUDGE ARE
PROCEEDING CAN BE DONE MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND SAFELY. FURTHER
THE PROVISION WAS AMENDED AND
THEN APPROPRIATIONS THEM OFF
AND BACK ON JANUARY ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. PRETTY
REVIEW RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THE YOU
VERY MUCH AND TO CLARIFY SOME
NUMBER YOU ARE PRESENTING- L.
WITH THE X. COMMITTEE MEDS THAT
RIGHT. THAT'S CORRECT CHAIR
THING YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHEN I MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MEDICARE LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FORTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FORTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. IN ONE MOMENT
HERE WE HAVE A FEW PEOPLE
QUEUING UP. MY NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS I'D
SAY LESLIE I'M A CO OWNER OF A
COURT REPORTING AGENCY WITH MY
WIFE WHO IS A PROUD FREELANCE
DEPOSITION REPORTER AND WE ARE
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THE COURT
REPORT REGULATION PART OF SB
TWO FORTY ONE. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CLICK COSTA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEFENSE
COUNSEL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SARAH
MCDEVITT CERTIFIED SHORTHAND
REPORTER NUMBER ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN FIVE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS DIANE FREEMAN AND I'M A
PROUD COURT REPORTER IN
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED SHORTHAND
REPORTER I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND AT
THE TIME OF DAY CARE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME IT PRIMARY WITNESSES
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE TWO.
AND WE BEGIN OUT WITH. LIBBY
SANCHEZ PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LED THE SANTOS
ON BEHALF OF AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
OFFICIAL COURT REPORTER
DEPLOYED BY THE COURTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY ONE POINT THAT WAS MADE
BY THE PROPONENTS WITNESS THAT
THIS BILL IS LIMITED. TO
WITNESS APPEARANCES THAT ARE
NON PRIMARY THERE IS NO.
LIMITATION THAT SPELL ALL
WITNESSES INCLUDING EVIDENTIARY
AND TESTIMONIAL WITNESSES COULD
APPEAR. REMOTELY PURSUANT TO
THIS MEASURE. REPORTER ATTACK
WITH PUTTING THE FAIR OF
OFFICIAL VERBATIM IN CORPUS.
THIS IS AN ENORMOUSLY DIFFICULT
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE COURT
REPORTERS HAVE BEEN FACED WITH
THE SAME TECHNOLOGICAL AN
OPERATOR IN OUR PROBLEMS WE'VE
ALL SEEN THIS YEAR FROM DROPPED
LINES TO WAR BLIER UNDEFINABLE
SPEAKERS. TO SPEAKERS NOT
KNOWING HOW TO MUTE OR UNMUTE
THEMSELVES THE COURT REPORTERS
THEMSELVES BEING MUTED AND
THEREFORE UNABLE TO ALERT THE
PRESIDING OFFICER OF THE
TECHNOLOGICAL PROBLEMS THAT
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO AN UNVIABLE
TRANSCRIPT. THIS HADN'T EVEN
BEEN THE WORST OF IT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED ATTEMPTED WITNESS
TAMPERING INCLUDING MINOR
CHILDREN JUDGES ADVISING THEM
TO JUST PUT IN AUDIBLE OR
UNINTELLIGIBLE EVEN THOUGH THEY
HAVE NO SUCH AUTHORITY UNDER
THEIR LICENSES FOR THE
HEARTBREAK OF A DESPERATELY
POOR PARENTS. HAVING THEIR
MINUTES RUN OUT ON THE PHONE IN
THE MIDST OF THEIR TESTIMONY
DURING A CHILD CUSTODY
PROCEEDING. UNLIKE ALL OF WHOM
SUCH TECHNOLOGICAL OR OPERATOR
ERROR PROBLEMS MIGHT NEARLY BE
OUR COME MY COURT REPORTERS
LICENSES ONLINE AND THAT'S NOT
JUST HYPOTHETICAL THERE ARE
CURRENTLY FILINGS BEFORE THE
COURT REPORTERS BOARD. ALLEGING
PROBLEMS WITH TRANSCRIPT ONE NO
SUCH. PROBLEMS OCCURRED. THIS
ISN'T THE ABOUT MY CORPORATE.
IT IS ABOUT LEADING ARE THE PUT
OF THE MEASURE MAY I KNOWING BE
A- TO DIFFERENT. THEMSELVES ON
THE ALL THAT IS BECAUSE THERE
IS NO REQUIRE UNDER THIS BILL
THAT BOTH PARTIES THE RAPPER.
OR EVEN A- OF THE POTENTIAL
IMPLICATIONS OF A GREEN HAVE A
WITNESS APPEAR REMOTELY WE'RE
TECHNOLOGICAL PROBLEMS ARISE.
THE LACK OF PROTECTIONS UNDER
THE SPELL MAKE THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENT THAT BOTH PARTIES
AGREE ALL BUT OBLIGATORY
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT UNDER
THIS BILL THAN THE FEDERAL
COURT REPORTER EMPLOYED BY THE
COURT. BE PRESENT DURING THE
PROCEEDINGS WERE WITNESSES
APPEAR REMOTELY EVEN THE COURT
REPORTERS MUST BE PROVIDED TO
INDIGENT LITIGANTS PERCENTAGE
ANISE AND DEDUCT THAT GIVEN THE
DRAMATIC DISPARITY BETWEEN
REPRESENTED AND UNREPRESENTED
PARTIES AND UNLAWFUL DETAINER
PROCEEDINGS. WERE 85290% OF
LANDLORDS ARE REPRESENTED AND
ONLY 3% OF TENANTS FROM
REPRESENTED THE DICHOTOMY OF
THIS BILL WILL NEGATIVELY
AFFECT MORE PEOPLE. BIRTH AND
HOW IT WILL POSITIVELY IMPACT
OF THE CLEAN FORGIVENESS JUNE
THIRTIETH EXPIRATION OF THE
EVICTION MORATORIUM COULD GIVE
US ALL GREAT PAUSE. REMOTE
APPEARANCES HAVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FAILURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SECONDARY- DURING TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE SECOND
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. MR A NOT SO
HERNANDEZ. PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTAMENT TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR AMANDA
ON BEHALF THE K. COURT.
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE PUBLIC
TO THE TWO FOR ONE. AT
CURRENTLY DRAFTED- IMAGES
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENT. ON THE
REMOTE PRECEDING PROVISION- TO
THE COMING OF THE SANCHEZ. I
THINK JERRY IS ALSO VERY
CONCERNED VERY OPPOSED TO THE
APPLICATION- WE JUST WENT OUT A
COUPLE OF THINGS- ONE IS WE
FOUND OUT RECENTLY. THERE IS A
CASE IN YELLOW COUNTY WHICH FOR
SIGNIFICANT- TECHNOLOGICAL
GIFT- DIFFICULT PEOPLE. AND AS
A RESULT THE CASE- HAD TO BE-
ME DOWN BECAUSE THERE'S ABOUT
TWENTY MINUTES OF A GAP. IN THE
ABILITY OF THE COURT REPORTER
TO SHARE THE TESTIMONY. AND
CELEBRATION CAPTAIN THROWN OUT
AND START ALL OVER AGAIN AND
THIS. TYPE OF PROBLEM HAS BEEN
OCCURRING THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WE'VE BEEN HEARING IT
REPEATEDLY. FROM OUR COURT
REPORTERS IN MOST COUNTIES IN
THE STATE IS JUST MOVING TOO
QUICKLY TOO SOON WITHOUT PROPER
ASSESSMENT. WELL ACTUALLY
TAKING THE- STATEMENT AND THE
CONCERNS ARE BEING RAISED BY
COURT REPORTER SERIOUSLY. WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO TELL FOLKS NOT
ONLY ON THIS BILL WELCOME TO
TRAILER BILL JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS AND
THEY'RE BEING IGNORED. SO WE
ASK THAT THE APPLICATION YOU
CAN START. ON GOING FORWARD%
WE'RE ALSO CLOSED- AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED TO THE PROVISION
RELATED TO. OUT OF STATE NON
LIKE MICKEY OWN CORPORATION
REGISTERING WITH THE- COURT
ORDERS FOR ME GREEN PRINCIPLE
AND WE HAVE SPONSORED BUILT IN
THIS AREA TO DO ALMOST THE-
EXACT SAME THING. IN OUR
EXPERTISE HAS RESULTED IN UP
AGAIN A FIND THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS WITH THIS
BILL. IF YOU LIVE ON STATUTES
THAT WERE CRAFTED SPECIFICALLY
FOR LICENSING. OR SPECIFICALLY
COLLECTIVELY OWNED FIRMS AND
NOW. THIS BILL EXPECTS THOSE
STATUTES TO SOMEHOW. APPLY-
ACCORDING TO THE DATA PLATFORMS
WE NEED STRONG STAFF. THAT ARE
MORE SPACE. OUT OF STATE MARK
TWAIN. WHO BE ALLOWED. OPERATE
HEARING CAL. WE DO NOT HAVE
STATURE ON THE BOOK NOW THAT
ATTRACT A TRAINED BEING SENT
OUT OF STATE YOU CAN PUT. AND
CHECK TO PARTY THAN THE TIME
FASHION WE DO NOT HAVE STATURE.
JEFF HAPPENS TO EXIT WHEN
THERE'S OUT OF. TO A
CORPORATION IF YOU THINK TAX.
THERE ARE LOT OF GAPS AND IF
DOCTOR ASKED. IT WILL CREATE AN
UNEVEN PLAYING FIELD IT WILL
CREATE- OVERSIGHT THAT IS
SIMPLY JUST NOT STRONG ENOUGH
ASSEMBLY BIRCH THE AUTHOR TO
WORK WITH US. TO MAKE THE BILL
MUCH STRONGER IF WE WANT
REGULATION TO OUT OF STATE ARE
LIKELY TO BE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE REST OF THE STATUTE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MEDICARE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
TWO FORTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND PUSH YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
FORTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. IMAMO MANAGER WE DO
HAVE PEOPLE QUEUING UP. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS KELLY SHANE LINE
CERTIFIED SHORTHAND REPORTER
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN THANK AND
CO FOUNDER OF PROTECT YOUR
RECORD PROJECT WE OPPOSE SB TWO
FORTY ONE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOUNG.
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAT MORAN WITH
AARON READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION OPPOSED
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. LIE
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME'S SANDY WALDRON I AM
PRESIDENT OF CPR AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MY NUMBER
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
I'M CAN CAUSE LAURA CERTIFIED
SHORTHAND REPORTER LICENSE
NUMBER EIGHT FIVE OH NINE I OWN
AND OPERATE BECAUSE OR
DEPOSITION REPORTERS IN FOLSOM
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE SB TWO
FORTY ONE FOR THE REASONS
STATED IN MY JUNE SIXTEEN
LETTER I SENT TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. IN AT THIS
TIME IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WHEN I MOVE THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MET
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BEGIN
WITH MISTER GIPSON FILED BY
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS. OF I'M GONNA TAKE
YOU OFF OF THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- BUT
I JUST HAVE CONCERNS- I THINK
THIS BILL IS. IS A DOUBLE I
DON'T OF THE BILL OF OVER FOR-
LET ME JUST OFF BY SIMPLY SAY-
THIS PANDEMIC IS CERTAINLY HAS.
HAS RAISED A NUMBER OF ISSUES-
THAT WE DIDN'T THINK THAT WAS
GOING TO REYES SPECIALLY HEALTH
DISPARITIES OF PEOPLE HAVING
ACCESS TO. HEALTH CARE BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR ME WHO
REPRESENT THE SIX BOARDS
THERE'S A GOOD STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. REALIZING THAT KIDS
DOING DISTANCE LEARNING I HAD
KIDS IN MY IN MY OWN COMMUNITY.
WHO DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
INTERNET SERVICES- BECAUSE THEY
LIVE IN PUBLIC SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING AND SAID A BLOCK WALLS
THAT SIGNAL CANNOT PENETRATE.
AND I'M I'M GOING SOMEWHERE
WITH THIS- AND LOOKING AT
BROADBAND SERVICES AND I KNOW
INTO LISTENING TO THE
TESTIMONIES OF THE PEPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY SPOKE. ONE PERSON
SAID- SOMEONE TO TURN TO WELL
I'M GONNA USE THAT PHRASE IN MY
IN MY COMMENTS. WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NO ONE TO TURN TO. IN
MY COMMUNITY AND ALL OVER THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS ACCESS TO KEEP
ACCESS TO BROADBAND INTERNET
SERVICES AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT. TRY TO USE THIS TECHNOLOGY
FOR JUSTICE IN THE COURT ROOM
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BARRIERS BECAUSE THEY WILL BE
THERE IF THEY IF THEY HAVE
INTERNET ACCESS THE AT HOME.
THEY THEY HAVE AT THE TO AT
HOME THEY HAVE NO ONE TO TRY TO
LEAST COACH THEM POLICE TELL
THEM WHAT TO SAY OR HAVING
LANGUAGE OR MATERIALS THAT THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND TO BE TO ASK
QUESTIONS. AND THEY'RE ON ON TV
OR INTERNET AND TRYING TO GET
THAT COMMUNICATION THAT
DIALOGUE WHICH IS A VERY- FOR
THEN YOU LOOK AT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NO ACCESS. WHO HAVE NO
INTERNET ACCESS TO BROADBAND
SERVICES AND YOU STILL LOOKING
AT A CERTAINLY A BERRIER WHEN
IT COMES DOWN TO WHEN IT COMES
DOWN TO THAT- AND- IF YOU LOOK
AT THE LAW- IS COMPLICATED. AND
WHAT PEOPLE HAVE TO STAND
BEFORE WHERE THE WITNESSES OR
OR OR TESTIFYING WHATEVER- IT
IS JUST IS NOT SUPPORTED LESS
THEY ACTUALLY IN A COURT ROOM
AND BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT
ABILITY- TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
LEVEL. PLAYING GIVEN TO UP AND
IT TO THAT. HAVING UMBILICAL
KIND OF WAY N TERMS OF. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A STATE THIS
VERY ROBUST WE HAVE
INTELLIGENCE AND EDUCATIONAL
LEVEL HERE BUT I'M HEARING THAT
WE- DEAL WITH PEOPLE FROM
OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA. TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES I THINK WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW
I CANNOT FEED MY NEIGHBOR'S
KIDS INVOLVED KIDS GOING HUNGRY
WITH THAT SIMPLY MEAN IS. THAT
CALIFORNIA'S COME FIRST PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS
WORK AND WE SHOULD NOT BE
RELYING ON OUT OF STATE- PEOPLE
TO DO THE KIND OF WORK THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CAN STAND UP. AND
CERTAINLY DO IN A VERY
QUALIFIED MATTER SO I WOULD.
JUST ASK THE- AUTHOR ONE- ARE
THEY AMENDMENTS THAT'S GOING TO
BE LOOKED AT AND WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO TRY TO COME
TO A MEDIUM- A MEDIUM GROUND SO
THAT WE CAN WORK THROUGH AND
PASSES BECAUSE THIS BILL HAS
COME BEFORE OUR HOUSE AND- AND
ACTUALLY BE VOTED. OUT OF THE
HOUSE AND SO TO- IF IN FACT DO
YOU THINK THAT- SOME OF THE
INFORMATION WITH RESPECT YOU
CAN ADDRESS AROUND BROADBAND
AND THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO INTERNET ACCESS-
BECAUSE AT THIS POINT ABOUT THE
LAY OFF OF THIS MY FIRST TIME
ACTUALLY LAYING OFF OF. OF THE
BILL- AND LOOKING AT AMENDMENT
SO IF THE- KIND SENATOR CAN
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE I'LL BE
HAPPY TO. LISTEN THANK YOU
SENATOR PER JUST BEFOREHAND
JUST ON TO. DRINK THE MEMBER
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
OBSERVATIONS AND JUST TO
REAFFIRM THAT IN THIS COMMITTEE
THE BILL BEFORE US RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TRYING TO STAY IN OUR
LANE WITH RESPECT TO. BEING P.
AS THIS IS DOUBLE EFFORT AS
WELL TO JUDICIARY SO IT AGAIN
AS WE HAVE THE BILL BEFORE US
WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO STAY WITHIN
THE FRAMEWORK. OF THE VISIT OF
PROFESSIONS CODE SPECIFICALLY
NONETHELESS THAT IS A- VALID
OKAY- ISSUE THAT YOU'VE ALSO
ADDRESSED MISTER GIBSON SO
SENATOR AMBER DO YOU WISH TO
ADDRESS. SETTING GIPSON
QUESTION THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE- ON
SEVERAL LEVELS FIRST OF ALL.
CONCERNING COURT REPORTERS
COURT REPORTERS. PROVIDE A VERY
VERY VALUABLE FUNCTION IN- AND-
MY OWN PER TRIAL PRACTICE
THEY'VE BEEN HELPFUL TELLING ME
WHEN I'M- NOT BEING CLEAR
TELLING ME WHEN I'M GARGLING MY
WORDS. SO THAT THE RECORD IS
ACCURATE UP THIS BILL AND WE
CAN MAKE IT EVEN MORE SPECIFIC.
DOES NOT ELIMINATE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT A COURT
REPORTER BE IN THE COURTROOM
WHENEVER TESTIMONY IS BEING
AKEN. I WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL OF
YOU TO CONTACT THE JUDGES YOU
KNOW IN YOUR DISTRICT THE
CONTACT FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGAL
AID SOCIETY IS THAT YOU KNOW IN
YOUR DISTRICT. BECAUSE WITH
RESPECT TO SOMEONE WHO IS
INDIGENT. LET'S JUST LET'S JUST
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE AN UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTION. AND UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTION IF YOU ARE
BEING- POTENTIALLY EVICTED AND
FOR EXAMPLE- YOU OR- YOUR
OPPONENT WISHES TO HAVE A
CONTINUANCE YOU CAN GO TO COURT
THERE IS NOTHING HERE THAT
PREVENTS YOU FROM GOING TO THE
COURTHOUSE. WHAT IT DOES DO
THOUGH IS FOR A HEARING THAT
WILL PROBABLY LAST LESS THAN
THREE MINUTES YOU CAN DO SO
FROM YOUR HOME IF YOU HAVE
CONNECTIVITY OR FROM A LIBRARY
IF YOU HAVE CONNECTIVE ITTY. OR
FROM LEGAL AID OFFICE. OR YOU
CAN WAIT FOR A DAY AND GO TO
COURT MISS A DAY OF WORK. AND
DO THAT. WHAT THIS DOES IS IT
IT SIMPLY CREATES EFFICIENCIES
AND IT IS EXTREMELY HELPFUL TO
THOSE WHO DON'T WANT TO MISS A
DAY OF WORK TO THOSE WHO CAN'T
MISS A DAY WORK SO THAT THEY
CAN PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. IT
ALSO CUTS DOWN IF YOU ARE A
LITIGANT IF YOU ARE A LITIGANT
AND YOU HAVE SOMEONE THAT NEEDS
TO IDENTIFY RECORDS YOU CAN
EITHER. HAVE THEM COME IN HANG
AROUND FOR A DAY OR YOU CAN
HAVE THEM TESTIFY REMOTELY.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE WE HAVE BEEN
DOING REMOTE TESTIMONY COURT
CALL FOR THIRTY YEARS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I REALIZE THAT
THERE IS A CONCERN ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY ENCROACHING ON COURT
REPORTERS RESPONSIBILITIES. OUT
WE WILL DO WHATEVER IS
NECESSARY TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT A COURT
REPORTER HAS TO BE IN THE
COURTROOM. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVE PARTICIPATED IN COURT
PROCEEDINGS YOU KNOW COURT
REPORTER SIMPLY RAISES HIS OR
HER HAND. AND THE JUDGE WAS
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
RECORD STOPS THE PROCEEDINGS
AND SAYS TO THE WITNESS I'M
SORRY YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO
REPEAT YOUR ANSWER FOR YOU
CAN'T SPEAK ON TOP ONE OF. THE
SAME IS TRUE IN A REMOTE
HEARING COURT REPORTER COULD DO
EXACTLY THE SAME THING SO I
DON'T HAVE ANY ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION BUT- I THINK THAT THIS
ISSUE IS ONE THAT- WILL
CERTAINLY BE ADDRESSED. IN
CLEAR FORM OF ITS NOT CLEAR NOW
CONSIDER A COURT REPORTER BEING
PRESENT COURTROOM. ASSEMBLY
GIPSON DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL FALTER OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I SUMMER
CUNNINGHAM. YEAH I WANT TO ALSO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE BILL
AND ADD JUST SOME PERSPECTIVE-
THAT I HAVE FROM BEING A
PRACTITIONER IN A COUNTY OF.
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE PRIMARILY- OUR
COURTS ARE SO IMPACTED RIGHT
NOW AND WE HAVE A SAYING IN THE
LAW JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED AND IT AFFECTS EVERY
SINGLE. FACET OF THE COURT
SYSTEM FAMILY LAW CUSTODY
PROCEEDINGS CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS CIVIL PROCEEDINGS
UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTIONS GOING
DOWN THE LIST. IN MY COUNTY
RIGHT NOW I FILED THE A
PETITION TO FOR DISMISSAL OF
THE CRIMINAL CONVICTION FOR
FORMER CLIENT. MISDEMEANOR D.
Y. IT WAS FINAL PROBATION
SERVICE PROBATION TERM NO
PROBLEMS THE STATUTE ITSELF
SAYS IT IS TO BE GRANTED AS A
MATTER OF RIGHT UNDER THOSE
CONDITIONS. MY COURTS BEEN
SITTING ON THAT FOR NINETY
DAYS. NINETY DAYS THIS
PARTICULAR CLIENT IS TRYING
HE'S HE'S IN INDIA HE'S A
PERMANENT RESIDENT. WANTS TO GO
BACK AND SEE HIS FAMILY IN
INDIA WHERE HIS PARENTS LIVE
AND HE CAN'T GET ON A PLANE
UNTIL THIS IS DONE. AND I'M THE
FREAKING ELECTED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO PRACTICES IN THIS.
IT'S SO IMPACTED RIGHT NOW. I
THINK. WHAT THE CENTER IS
TRYING TO DO WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT OVER THE LAST TWENTY MONTHS
ABOUT EFFICIENCY THERE'S A LOT
OF THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE
ELECTRONICALLY VIA ZOOM OUR
COURTS HAVE MOVED HEAVEN AND
EARTH TO GET THAT THE SYSTEM
SET UP AND WE'VE SEEN WHAT'S
WORKED WHAT HASN'T WORKED. A
BUT UNLESS WE TAKE SOME STEPS
TO INCREASE THE EFFICIENCY IN
THE SYSTEM. YEAH THERE'S
ANOTHER SIDE OF THAT IMPACT
IT'S THE PETITIONS FOR
EXPUNGING CRIMINAL RECORDS ARE
GETTING HURT IT'S THE UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTIONS ARE GETTING
HURT IT'S I MEAN YOU NAME IT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME RIGHT NOW AT
LEAST IN MY COUNTY OR THE TWO
COUNTIES I PRACTICE IN. THE
ONLY TRIAL YOU CAN EVEN GET ON
A CALENDAR. IS A CRIMINAL TRIAL
WITHOUT A TIME WITH. ANYTHING
ELSE YOU'RE BEING PUT OUT.
MONTHS IF NOT YEARS. WE HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE WE WANT TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES AND SETTLE ISSUES AND
WE'VE GOT TO DO IT EFFICIENTLY.
AND IF WE DON'T. THE INJUSTICE
FALLS HARDEST ON THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE THE LEAST ABLE TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES. BY HIRING
EXPENSIVE LAWYERS TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM WORK FOR THEM. IF THEY
CAN EVEN MAKE THEM WORK. IF
THEY CAN EVEN MAKE THE SYSTEM
WORK. SO I JUST WANT TO OFFER
THAT PERSPECTIVE THE IMPACT ON
OUR COURT SYSTEM RIGHT NOW IS
REAL. THE DELAY. THAT
EVERYBODY'S FACING ISRAEL. AND
I'VE I THINK THIS MEASURE WILL
WILL DO SOMETHING TO HELP
ALLEVIATE THAT AND MOVE TOWARDS
A LITTLE BIT MORE EFFICIENCY.
AND I THINK THAT THE ISSUE WITH
THE COURT REPORTER I THINK
WE'VE HEARD IS COMMITMENT. TO
WORKING THAT OUT OVER TIME AND
I THINK THAT THAT CAN BE DONE.
AND YES THE SAME PROCESS CAN
BE. EMPLOYED AND HIM. HE
ANSWERED THE QUESTION THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT POINT. NOBODY IS
BEING FORCED TO DO ELECTRONIC
THINGS YOU CAN STILL ORDER THIS
BILL IF NOT CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG. YOU CAN STILL COME INTO
COURT. IF YOU WANT TO DRIVE TO
DOWNTOWN LA FROM HER YOU HAVE
FOR WHEREVER YOUR- YOUR THINGS
VENUE DO YOU STILL HAVE THAT
OPTION SO I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT. HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE. I HOPE IT PASSES
BECAUSE WE. WE DEFINITELY NEED
SOME HELP IN THE COURT SYSTEM.
THANK VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA FOLLOWED
BY SOME IMMIGRATION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. I REPRESENT
RIVERSIDE SO VERY AWARE. OF
THE- CLOGGING OF OUR COURTS.
ABOUT IT BUT I THINK- ONE ISSUE
ON THAT WOULD BE- MORE JUDGES.
ESPECIALLY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AND I SHARE THE CONCERN THAT I
HEARD. FROM ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LA HERE. ON
I'LL JUST THE INEFFICIENCY. OF
THE TECHNOLOGY. THAT WE'VE SEEN
IT HERE. OF FIRST HAND ON THIS
FLOOR- IN IN OUR HEARINGS WERE.
THINGS GO OUT- AS AN EDUCATOR.
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
DIFFICULT IT HAD BEEN FOR
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
STUDENTS A TO DO DISTANCE
LEARNING AND THE FAILURE. OF
THE TECHNOLOGY SO WHEN I HEARD
COURT REPORTERS SAYING. THE DAY
FACED THOSE SAME CHALLENGES-
I'M SYMPATHETIC AND JUST
WONDERING IF THE SENATOR JUST
MIGHT. WANT TO ADDRESS AGAIN-
YOUR RESPONSE TO THE COURT
REPORTERS WHO SAY THAT THAT
IT'S A FAILURE OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT MAKES THEIR JOB IS COURT
REPORTERS- ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
DO I KNOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT. SURE THROUGH THE
CHAIR. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- LET ME LET ME CLEAR UP
SOME MISCONCEPTIONS. IT
TECHNOLOGY FAILS THE JUDGE IS
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CONDUCT OF THE COURTROOM AND
TRANSCRIPT TO LAWYERS. TWO OR
MORE LAWYERS ARE RESPONSIBLE TO
REPRESENT THEIR INDIVIDUAL
PARTIES AND SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE IS NOT AN ACCURATE
RECORD THEY HAVE A- INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE IT'S ACCURATE IF
TECHNOLOGY FAILS. WHEN IT FAILS
OCCASIONALLY THEN THEY STOP AND
THEY SAY OKAY EVERYBODY'S GOT
TO COME IN IF THAT'S THE CASE
WELL WE'VE GOT TO WAIT TILL IT
GETS FIXED. TO SIMPLY SAY WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK IN TIME. WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK IN TIME TO A
TIME LIKE A HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS
AGO. LITERALLY A HUNDRED FIFTY
YEARS AGO WHERE EVERYONE HAS TO
BE IN COURT INCLUDING THE
CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS INCLUDING
MINISTER WITNESSES INCLUDING
EVERYBODY WHO HAS. A TWO MINUTE
APPEARANCE SO FOR EXAMPLE GOING
BACK TO UNLAWFUL DETAINERS.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE
GOING TO. EVEN IF WE HAVE MORE
JUDGES WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO EXACERBATE. THE CRISIS THAT
ALREADY EXISTS SO THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT SAFEGUARDS
TO LAWYERS HAVE TO STIPULATE BY
THE WAY. TO THE PARENTS OF A
WITNESS IF THEY DON'T STIPULATE
AND ONE BELIEVES THAT SOMEHOW
THAT WITNESSES SIMPLY
MINISTERIAL THEY CAN MAKE A
MOTION THE JUDGE BUT THE JUDGE
HAS A NUMBER OF CRITERIA TO GO
THROUGH. AND IF THE JUDGE IS
WRONG THEN THERE'S AN ISSUE ON
APPEAL. THERE ARE A NUMBER
PROTECTIONS HERE- I CAN'T
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THAT. WE'RE
GONNA MAKE SURE THAT THIS DOES
NOT ENCROACH UPON COURT RISK
RECORDABLE RESPONSIBILITIES OUR
PRESENCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SIMILAR GRAYSON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I DO WANNA
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES- BOTH FROM THE
BACKLOGS IN THE COURTS- TO THE
CONCERNS OF THE COURT
REPORTERS. AND BASED ON THE PER
VIEW OF THIS COMMITTEE I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL- BUT I
DO KNOW- BEING REFERRED TO-
ANOTHER COMMITTEE WILL BE
LOOKING FORWARD TO HOW YOU'RE
ABLE TO NAVIGATE AND ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO.
THE TECHNOLOGY SIDE OF IT AND
IT MAY BE THAT TECHNOLOGY FAILS
BUT IT ONLY FAILS ON ONE
PARTY'S PART AND SO IT'S MAYBE
NOT KNOWN THROUGHOUT THE REST
OF THE PARTY- WHO HAPPENS TO BE
ON THAT CALL OUR- WORD
DEPENDING ON TECHNOLOGY TO GET-
THE TESTIMONY THROUGH. SO AGAIN
JUST TRYING TO PROVIDES
PROTECTIONS FOR THE COURT
REPORTERS AND YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT AND THE NEXT COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN- AND- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND-
SENATOR AS YOU HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES- THERE ARE A LOT OF
CONCERNS I AM GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE- THE PORTION OF THE
BILL THAT'S UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THIS COMMITTEE
I CERTAINLY HAVE NO. ISSUES
WITH BUT I HAVE HEARD FROM MY
LOCAL- THEIR CONCERNS SO I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH- THE OPPOSITION GOING
FORWARD AND I KNOW THIS IS
GOING TO GO IN FRONT OF
JUDICIARY SO. I'M ASSUMING THE
BILL WILL BE- CLEANED UP. BY
THE TIME IT GETS TO THE FLOOR
THAT'S A BY WILL BE SPORTING
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIP. I'M JUST GONNA
ALSO BRIEFLY ASSOCIATE MYSELF
FOR THE LAST FEW COMMENTS AS A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE BUT
ALSO SIMPLY JUDICIARY MY HOPE
IS THAT BY WE GET BY THE TIME
WE GET TO JUDICIARY SOME OF
THESE ISSUES WILL BE. MORE
DEEPLY LOOKED INTO GIVEN THE
PURVIEW OF THAT AS- AS YOU WELL
KNOW GIVEN YOUR CURRENT
CHAIRMANSHIP SO LOOK FOR TO THE
DISCUSSION THERE BUT FOR
PURPOSES OF TODAY. ARE HAPPY TO
HELP WITH THIS FOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME CNN. SENATOR I'M
PARTY WISH TO CLOSE. UP WELL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INPUT- I
WOULD ENCOURAGE. YOU TO CONTACT
THOSE WHO REPRESENT INDIGENTS
IN YOUR DISTRICT AND JUDGES IN
YOUR DISTRICT AND PRACTITIONERS
IN YOUR DISTRICT AS- AS YOU.
HEARD EARLIER BOTH DEFENSE
COUNSEL AND- CONSUMER COUNCIL.
BOTH SUPPORT THE BILL URGEN I
BOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
PLEASE HAVE A MOTION. GAVE ME A
MOVE BY SOMEONE OR WIN SECOND
BY SUMMER CUNNINGHAM COULD BE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA HI
BERMAN. BERMAN HI BLOOM. CHEN
Q. CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HI DELHI DELHI HI
FONG. GIPSON. FONG HI GIPSON.
NOT VOTING GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN IRWIN
HI MCCARTY. MEDINA. IN AN
APPARENT MULLIN. SALAS SALAS I
EIGHTEEN. AND WEBER WEBER HI.
MULLIN AYE. THIRTY NINE ZERO
KNOWS. THIRTEEN IS THAT BILLS
OUT BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REMEMBER
POGS WERE JUST GONNA GO BACK TO
AN ORDER THEN FOR ADDITIONAL.
ADD ONS. CONSENT ITEM S. B.
FOUR ONE FOUR JONES. DO YOU
PASSED A LOCAL GUY F. QIU.
HOLDEN HOLDEN I MCCARTY DAVID.
SALAS SALAS I TEAM OUR TEAM HI.
TO OUR. EIGHTY NINE ZERO KNOWS
THE BILL IS OUT. SB FOUR EIGHT
FOUR ARCHULETA DO YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN. BERMAN I
QIU QIU I GIPSON GIPSON HI
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
JACKIE IRWIN IRWIN I MCCARTY.
MULLIN MULLIN AYE SALAS SALAS I
TEAM TEAM I. SIXTEEN I ZERO
KNOWS FIFTEEN IS THE BILL
WITHOUT. SB FIVE THREE FOUR
JONES TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BLOOM. QIU QIU ONLINE GIPSON
GIPSON HI HOLDEN HOLDEN I
MCCARTY. MEDINA MULLIN. MULLIN
AYE SALAS SALAS I TEAM TEAM I.
EIGHTEEN AYE ZERO KNOWS YOU CAN
IS THE BILL IS OUT. SB FIVE
FOUR FOUR WHERE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM. QIU QIU I
GIPSON GIPSON HI HOLDEN. HOLDEN
I MCCARTY MEDINA. SALAS SALAS I
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN I. SIXTEEN
NINE ZERO KNOWS. FIFTEEN AYE
THE BILL IS OUT. SB THREE TEN
RUBIO QIU QIU I EIGHTEEN
CORRECTION NINETEEN ICE ZERO
NOW NINETEEN AS THE BILL IS OUT.
SB TWO FOUR ONE NUMBER TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY BLOOM.
CHEN MCCARTY. THIRTEEN NINE
ZERO KNOWS THIRTEEN EYES THAT
BILL IS OUT. AND WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. IT IS HE.
LIVE IT WILL
MEAN I ACCEPT IT THANK YOU BOB
FRANKEN IS TO BECOME OKAY.
YEAH.
SB TWO FOUR ONE NUMBER TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY CHEN.
CHEN HI. FOURTEEN ZERO KNOWS.
WE GET A CHANCE TO. RIGHT.
RIGHT. THE BILL THAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. OKAY. DELCOURT. YEAH
YEAH. YEAH. YEAH WE DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S RIGHT SB FIVE THREE
FOUR JONES TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM BLOOM HIGH.
NINETY NINE ZERO NOW WITH. SB
FIVE FOUR FOUR WHERE DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM BLOOM I.
SEVENTEEN AYE ZERONOS. SB TWO
FOUR ONE NUMBER TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY BLOW.
BLOOM I. FIFTEEN AYE ZERO KNOWS.
THANK YOU. OF COURSE HAVE A
GREAT DAY. IF YOU. THE CARD.
YEAH WHATEVER ORDER MURDER
FORGET THAT EITHER EITHER
WORKED OUT IN THE MIDDLE. AND
IT'S NOT. YEAH. EVERY EVERY
TIME. I DID GO TO DIAL ON THEIR-
HI MY NAME IS CALLED. PROBEM
WITH TECHNOLOGY YOUR MIND IS A
VOTED I. OKAY RIGHT NOW. SB
FIVE FOUR FOUR LAYER TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEDINA MEDINA HI
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IS
THOROUGHNESS. NO NOT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THIS MCCARTY RIGHT
FOR WHAT YOU WANT TO GO SORRY
KILLING. LOCAL IN THE LAST
QUARTER. YEAH THE WRITTEN
YOU'VE BEEN AROUND A LONG LONG
WAY YOU KNOW ALL THE STUFF.
WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH THE NEW
MATERIAL THEIR FOR THIS YOU
CAN'T REALLY. THROUGH THROUGH.
ALL THE PART OF HIS NETWORK-
ALL HAVE A PART OF YOU.
SB FOUR
ONE FOUR JONES DO YOU PASSED A
LOCAL GUY HAVE. MCCARTY MCCARTY
I. NINETEEN AYE AYES ZERO KNOWS.
S. B. FOUR EIGHT FOUR. SB FOUR
EIGHT FOUR ARE TWO LETTER TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MCCARTY
MCCARTY I SEVENTEEN ISER ONO'S.
SB FIVE THREE FOUR JONES DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. NINETY NINE
ZERO KNOWS. SB FIVE FOUR FOUR
LAYERED DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MCCARTY MCCARTY
I. NINETEEN AYE ZERONOS. SB
THREE ONE ZERO RUBIO TO PASS
CHIU HEALTH COMMITTEE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I. NINETY NINE ZERO
KNOWS. AND SB TWO FOUR ONE
AMBERG TO PASSAGE AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY MCCARTY MCCARTY HI.
SIXTEEN ICE ZERO KNOWS.